when you went to the Oscars this time
they did not want you to be in character
right that's right that's right okay so
the the the way I heard it is you were
like [ __ ] you I'm going to the Oscars
you snuck in my wife's gonna hide the
outfit yeah in her purse or something
yeah and I am gonna go backstage
and I'm gonna come out and present with
Olivia Wilde beautiful woman but
beautiful beautiful and I am going to do
whatever the hell I want
yes right are you nervous at this point
to do something like that oh you've done
this so many times that you're not
nervous no I was nervous I'll tell you
why because obviously the ratio issue
was a big issue at the Oscar is the the
issue the issue and I decide you know
what I'm gonna do Ali G and the problem
is you know the HBO show was a while
back it was 10 years ago right
at its height it had maybe a million and
a harm viewers the Oscars is going out
to 300 million people right and I think
all right I'm doing a character who
thinks he's black but they're gonna
introduce me as Sacha Baron Cohen and my
first line is going to be I know what
you was all thinking you know the
Academy has brought on yet another token
black presenter I love that line so I'm
thinking all right if you know a lychee
you're gonna realize that's funny if you
don't know who Ali G is in other words
99% of people out there you're gonna
think that Sacha Baron Cohen is becoming
pretending to be black right and so I
did get white and then on the way in the
way I told two people I told one English
guy and the other guy said don't tell
anyone you know I'm I'm gonna do Ellijay
right and he goes up really I carry this
is my first line tell me what you think
because do not do that man that's
actually racist he's coked that's racial
it racially and then on the way in I saw
Dave Chappelle haha I'm like they've
taken me backstage I was like I met Dave
once before I think it's a great
comedian a great comedian I said Dave
he's like with his posse I got Dave I
need you for 35 seconds please is that
right Dave I'm going on and doing Ali G
this is my first line tell me whether
I'm gonna get killed
he's like it's great get out then do it
and so we went backstage and then me and
my wife
disappear into this toilet for 40
minutes because she has to put on the
beard you know with the glue by the way
what was dave chappelle doing at the
oscars I've got no idea yeah because I
mean he was and why was he not
boycotting didn't appear on stage right
so what Chappelle had said no to you and
said I think that's kind of racist you
would have done that opening like as I I
probably I was worried about the oh
because again logically there was a
problem with it in that if most people
most people would think I'm a racist you
know which I didn't want to do say you
couldn't just do a joke for the 1% are
you sure it was Chappelle
thank you we talked Rock did you talk to
him at all yes yeah now you're in the
bathroom you're hiding out for 45
minutes while your wife but basically LA
is the only place where you can
disappear into the bathroom with another
woman but aren't they looking for you
you looking for me and like I've got my
publicist telling them that I've got
terrible diarrhea and so we set it out
beforehand he's got really bad there and
we've smuggled all the stuff in I've got
some stuff on me we've got a bag she's
got stuff you know so when you walk out
in your allergy outfit so I didn't so I
didn't so basically I walk out in the
beard I'm covering my hand over my beard
so now they're all looking at the stage
I walk to the edge of the stage and then
Olivia was there I'm standing back there
and suddenly he shows up next to me and
he seemed really nervous and he wasn't
in the allergy costume right and I was
like are you okay he's like hmm let's do
this and the stage manager walked away
and the second he was out of sight
Sasha was like yeah and he handed me the
the hat and he's like took my hair into
the Hat took my hair tonight I put his
hair in and he put the glasses on and
I'm a huge allergy fan yes yes I didn't
know how she was gonna react and she was
great she talks in my hair puts in her
thing there which is you want I go yeah
so that's it I knew I had five seconds
to tell her and get it done
I'm doing allergy tuck in my hair do you
think she gets upset because maybe it's
taking away from her know she loves that
she loved it she goes along with it she
loved it